vamos a resolver otro ejercicio de
ecuaciones diferenciales de segundo
orden que sean lineales y homogéneas
esta vez voy a tomar la siguiente
ecuación quiero que pone mucha atención
es cuatro veces la segunda derivada de i
con respecto a x menos ocho veces la
primera derivada de que con respecto a x
ya eso le voy a sumar tres veces y la
voy a igualar a cero bien y voy a tomar
las siguientes condiciones iniciales y
evaluada en el punto cero esta vez va a
ser 2 y prima es decir la primera
derivada de ye evaluada en el punto cero
va a ser un medio en los vídeos
anteriores vimos con mucha calma cómo
realizar este tipo de ejercicios en esta
ocasión quiero verlo de una manera más
rápida y que sea mucho más mecánica
la idea era vulnera e iguala a la rx
para así derivar la una vez para así
derivar las dos veces y sustituir en la
ecuación diferencial segundo orden y así
poder sacar el polinomio característico
este pueblo característico lo vamos a
ocupar bastante para resolver la
solución de esta ecuación diferencial
más aún voy a escribir el polinomio
característico de una vez aquí va a ser
cuatro ere cuadrada menos 8 r 3 r esto
va a ser igual a 0 de esta ecuación
característica lo que queremos es
encontrar sus raíces entonces tenemos 4
erre cuadrada porque está en la segunda
derivada menos 8 r porque está en la
primera derivada más 3 r más 13 r yo
creo que no tiene sentido aquí tengo un
pequeño error nuestra ser vamos a
tacharlo no es 3 solito a secas ok
entonces le queda 4 de cuadrada menos 8
r 3 igual a 0 la cual la podemos
resolver no está fácil factor izando
pero si por fórmula general del segundo
grado aquella que dice así - b más menos
la raíz cuadrada de b cuadrada menos 4
hace todo eso entre 2 a entonces
sustituyendo que nos va a quedar pues
que r va a ser igual a menos p - 8 x
menos pues es 8 positivo
más menos la raíz cuadrada de ocho
cuadrados pero ocho cuadrados 64 menos 4
veces a que vale 4 por c que vale 3
todo esto dividido entre dos veces o sea
ocho bien pero esto cuánto es 8 + - la
raíz cuadrada de 64 menos 4 por 4 puntos
16 por 3 es 16 por 13 48 muy bien y todo
esto dividido entre 8 cuánto es 64 menos
48 64 menos 48 pues es 20 menos 4 que es
16 sí claro 64 puntos 48 16 y entonces
voy a poner 8 más menos la raíz de 16
todo esto entre 8 esto va a ser 8 más
menos la raíz 16 64 entre 8 y si divido
entre 8 me va a quedar pues 8 entre 81
más menos 4 entre 8 que es un medio
entonces ya tengo las dos raíces de r
que cumplen esta ecuación característica
en para que no me confunda voy a borrar
una vez que esté tachón y que quede bien
bien borrado bien se ve ya mucho mejor y
así no me voy a confundir r va a ser
igual a la primera raíz pues es uno más
un medio que son tres
y la segunda raíz me va a quedar en este
caso uno un medio que es un medio muy
bien
para que saque las raíces yo saqué estas
raíces de mi polino un característico
debido a que esas me van a servir para
hacer una combinación de dos suman dos
con mis funciones exponenciales
es decir la solución general me va a
quedar que igual hace uno por el ala
tres medios x es decir la primera raíz
por x más de dos y al a un medio x es
decir la segunda raíz por x de este
polinomio característico sacamos las dos
raíces que no sirvieron para encontrar
la solución general pero es hora de
utilizar las condiciones iniciales pero
antes de utilizarlas fíjense voy a
ocupar la primera derivada de y entonces
hagamos la de una vez
mi prima va a ser igual y pues bajamos
la constante entonces me queda tres
medios de c-1 y a la tres medios de
más un medio bajamos la constante por
cerdos y al a un medio de x muy bien
como ya no me cabe nada aquí voy a
reescribir otra vez las condiciones
iniciales que es con el que voy a
trabajar ahorita y voy a terminar de
resolver este problema sacando las
constantes aquí estando otra vez mis
condiciones iniciales y bajemos el
pizarrón perfecto ok pero entonces me
falta sustituir no quiere 0 es igual a 2
entonces pues sustituyendo que me queda
si pongo 0 en lugar de x pues a la 01
entonces solamente me quedase 1 más de 2
porque a la 0 pues es otra vez 1 por 0 2
pues ese 2 y esto por mis condiciones
iniciales tienen que ser igual a 2 bien
y ahora es tiempo de utilizar la otra
condición inicial que tiene que ver con
la primera derivada entonces
sustituyamos a x por el valor de 0 que
me va a quedar tres medios de c-1
por el acero que vuelva a ser uno más un
medio de c2 por el ala un medio por cero
pero un medio por cero volvemos a lo
mismo es cero el acero es uno y esto va
a ser igual pues al valor que teníamos
en nuestra condición inicial que es un
medio y si se dan cuenta ya tengo otra
vez un sistema de ecuaciones en el cual
yo tengo dos incógnitas y dos ecuaciones
entonces pues en un principio podemos
intentar resolverlo
si multiplico yo la primera ecuación por
tres medios esto me va a servir para
ello poderlas cancelar cambiando el
color azul pues me queda tres medios c1
estoy multiplicando la primera ecuación
por tres medios más tres medios de s2 y
esto va a ser igual a tres medios por
dos pero pues el 2002 se cancela y
entonces esto me queda tres bien y ahora
qué pasa si yo resto
la ecuación número dos a la ecuación
número tres es decir tres medios de ese
uno menos tres medios de ese uno pues se
van un medio de ese dos menos tres
medios de c2 esto me queda menos 1 c 1 c
o sea menos de 2 y esto va a ser igual a
un medio menos 3 pero 3 son 6 medios y
entonces esto me queda cinco medios
negativo aunque imperfecto pero el 12 2
pues es cinco medios positivos porque
paso el signo del otro lado o nos
canceló
bien si sustituyó en la primera ecuación
me queda que sea 15 medios es igual a 2
porque ese 2 valía 5 medios y si yo paso
del otro lado el 5 medios y veo que 2 es
igual a 4 medios pues entonces me queda
menos un medio con este sistema de
ecuaciones yo ya logré determinar
mis dos constantes la primera es igual a
menos un medio y la segunda el 5 medios
entonces yo ya puedo sustituir en la
ecuación general y así poder encontrar
la solución particular con estas
condiciones iniciales c1 era menos un
medio por tres medios de x
más de 20 cerdos vale 5 medios entonces
me va a quedar 5 medios y a la segunda
raíz que era un medio entonces me va a
quedar
un medio de x y es así como hemos
terminado de resolver nuestra ecuación
diferencial de segundo orden que era
lineal y que era homogénea pero quiero
que sea en cuenta un par de
observaciones para finalizar quiero que
veamos que resolver esta ecuación
diferencial se basó completamente en
elementos de álgebra en resolver una
ecuación cuadrática y en resolver un
sistema de ecuaciones la ecuación
cuadrática salió de asociar un polinomio
característico que era muy fácil pues en
la segunda derivada ponemos el cuadrado
en la primera r en la función normal no
ponemos ninguna r y entonces resolvimos
así una ecuación de segundo grado que
tenía que ver con dos raíces de un
polinomio característico ya después
trabajé con dos constantes las cuales
las podría resolver con un sistema de
ecuaciones dadas las condiciones
iniciales y con todo esto
la solución particular a mi ecuación
diferencial es todo por esta vez y nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo